president biden has a brilliant new plan
that will heal the economy
aoc has some incisive thoughts on the
border crisis and dr
jill biden isn't only a great doctor she
speaks spanish beautifully
april fools i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them
at expressvpn.com we'll get to all the
news
in just one moment because we can see
we'll get to that in one second first
thousands of customers are canceling the
nation's largest wireless providers why
they found out they can get the same
service at half the price by switching
over
to pure talk usa that is correct instead
of charging obscene fees to pay for
their massive mainstream media campaigns
corporate campuses and retail outlets
across the country puretalk passes the
savings on to you
the average family saves over 800
dollars a year
and switching is super easy you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you go over on the
data
they're not going to charge you for it
from your cell phones i'll pound 250 say
ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month that's pound
two five zero say ben shapiro to get
started you're paying way too much for
your wireless bill if you can save
nearly a thousand dollars a year by
switching wireless providers and get the
same exact coverage
what in the world are you doing these
wireless providers they sort of fib to
you about what exactly you need what you
actually need i'm gonna talk tax 6 gigs
of data 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for that is a
fantastic deal that's why so many people
are switching over to pure talk
particularly my listeners to i'll pound
250 say ben shapiro to get started
today alrighty so when you look at our
political class
i i have to admit i do not understand so
many americans who look
at our political class at shows like
this one or shows on cnn or msnbc
and they see these talking ads who are
our elected officials or our regulators
and they think to themselves
these people are geniuses these people
need to be in charge of my life
they clearly know what is best for me
they clearly know what is best for my
family they clearly know
what is best for my business how do you
look at these people and you think to
yourself
what they i require them to have more
control
over my life honestly if that's what you
want it's what you're gonna get
good and hard but it's it's not right
guys because it turns out that the
people who are in charge
are stupid they are stupid the vast
majority of them are dum-dums you know
why because the vast majority of people
on planet earth are dum-dums except when
it comes to their own affairs
there they are self-interested there
they tend to think out what they do
there they have to live with the
consequences of what they do personal
responsibility is a fabulous teacher
but when you cast all responsibility off
to the government to either take care of
you or make the rules for your life you
can blame them for your own failures
which i guess is the attraction
and also those people can then be given
all of the power to shape your life as
they see fit i guess that's the
attraction
doesn't seem that attractive to me
because frankly these people are morons
they are so unbelievably stupid
and yes i mean at the top levels of
american government okay joe biden
is not with us he is not with us he is
not a sentient human
and yet you are telling joe biden this
not sentient human this house plant of a
human
you are telling him that you want him to
be in charge of your life and he just
says things
on a routine basis that make no sense at
all now today
i want to talk about how excited i am
about some of the things he's saying
because frankly
i'm very excited in fact i think that we
ought to do many of the things he is
saying for example
he apparently did an interview on espn
with
sage steele in which he said
i'm not kidding you joe biden said it is
time for women athletes to be paid
on par or the same as male athletes
quote
i don't think it's right i don't i don't
think it's fair
and then he fell asleep and then they
woke him up and they fed him some insure
and then he went back to sleep
so he thinks that female athletes should
be paid the same as male athletes right
which is the same thing that he said
over the past couple of weeks when he
did that ridiculous press conference
with the one of the biggest whiners in
american society megan rappano
who is far more famous than her
accomplishments
really i think would warrant i mean
she's really famous for political
purposes there are a lot of other
women's soccer players who are on that
team none of them are as famous as megan
rapino
she might be the most famous player on
that team because she's the most
talented
still there are many other famous and
talented soccer players over the course
of female soccer history who don't have
her level
of notoriety and that is solely because
of politics in any case
joe biden does that presser about how
women and men aren't paid the same and
it's really unfair and the women should
be the same paid the same as men in
soccer
i i notice that you know what they never
discuss is basketball
they never discuss basketball and this
seems to me a grave injustice
i do not want to live in an america
in which female basketball players are
not paid the same for the same work
as male basketball players i don't want
to live in that kind of america we're
better than this
america i don't want to live in an
america in which djuan of honor the
highest paid player
in the wnba which is just a fabulous
league
a wildly popular league the wnba
everyone walked everyone i know watches
the wnba
everybody all over the world loves the
wnba the wnba
is one of the most important leagues in
the history of the world
i mean like in terms of sporting
accomplishment like let's be real about
this the wnba
is spectacular spectacular it is just
great action
it's why it's why literally hundreds of
people grab their rafters
at each game sorry i couldn't make it
through that okay
but i don't want to live honestly it's
just unfair
the systems of white supremacy have
extended so far into american society
they've extended into every area every
nook and cranny
of american life i don't want to live in
an america where dwana bonner
the highest paid player in the wnba
earns 215
000 a year for the same exact work
the same exact work mind you as steph
curry who makes 43
million dollars a year i don't want to
live in that kind of america
just because dejuana bonner happens to
identify as female and steph curry
happens to identify as male he makes
42 million 800 thousand dollars more
than zawana bonner how dare america this
must be rectified immediately
immediately and i call on the democratic
party which is in favor of equity to
immediately call for the
collectivization
of all player earnings in the wnba and
the nba and redistribution evenly
along sex lines dejuana bonner
immediately needs to take half of steph
curry's salary she should be making
21 million dollars a year in fact not
only that
that's not even fair because it turns
out that tawanna bonner is the highest
paid player in the wnba
what we really need to do is we need to
take all the players in the wnba
and all the players in the nba we need
to pool all their salaries and then we
need to divvy them up equally
because let me tell you this dewanna
bonner she is
just as valuable a person in every
respect
as as lebron james and just because
lebron james
might be bigger and stronger and male
just because of that that does not mean
that he ought to be
earning as much money as he is earning
why is it that he ought to be earning
the same amount of money
like 41 million dollars a year while sue
bird of the seattle storm
the massively popular seattle storm is
earning only 215 000
a year i mean brittany griner on the
phoenix mercury is only earning 215
000 a year and meanwhile you have like
giannis
and that guy's earning 40 million it is
unfair it is wrong
it is un-american it has to stop today
joe biden needs to sponsor federal
legislation to make sure that everything
is redistributed
or alternatively joe biden is uh is a
very stupid man who says stupid things
on a routine basis like many of our
politicians and like all the people who
want to control your life see here's the
thing
if i think everybody is stupid the only
smart politician is the one who
recognizes his own stupidity enough
to know that he should let you run your
own life okay speaking of
people screwing things up the greatest
doctor in our land
dr jill biden who is i mean again the
rankings go like
dr joe biden dr anthony fauci
dr j dr pepper jonas salk
hippocrates that's the rankings of
doctors historically not just in
american society
over time historically okay dr joe biden
the greatest doctor of all
if you have a heart attack dr jill will
immediately arrive on scene and
recommend to you
how to fix the community college program
so yesterday
she was giving a speech in which she was
talking about something that nobody
knows
i think she's talking about illegal
immigration uh she was talking about
labor
as to honor the birthday of cesar chavez
and um it didn't go amazing remember
that time that melania trump never made
the cover of a magazine despite being a
fashion model
and melania trump was a terrible person
and very stupid according to the media
even though she spoke five languages
remember that but jill biden is the most
brilliant among us she's just
she's a sterling example of american
intellect
here is dr joe biden yesterday now
listen as somebody who routinely screws
up foreign languages i have a little bit
of sympathy here but not much because
sisa puede
happens to be the most commonly spoken
spanish sentence by white people in
america
really you want to know why because
barack obama said it all the time
right during the 2008 campaign he said
it all the time in fact
everybody who grew up with the disney
channel from 2002 gotta kick it up guys
gotta kick it up
si si pueda it's been a thing for a very
long time in white america si se puede
via cultural appropriation or whatever
um somehow
joe biden screwed up like this is not an
obscure phrase exactly and again
this is coming from a guy i understand i
don't speak spanish well i screwed up la
quinta yesterday like i i
i get it but this one it's a little much
even for me here was it joe biden
not even coming close to uh sisa puede
so say it with me si se quadre
the future is ours thank you
[Music]
oh my god not only is she america's
greatest doctor she's also a translator
for the united nations
according to the establishment media
according to our partisan media she is
she is just the best my favorite part of
this is when it pulls out
and she she finishes on this hi like
that wasn't just in the middle of the
speech that was her closer
sisa puad way san diego padres
in honor of opening day and uh and then
they pull out and
you can see the teleprompters and they
pull out and it's like eight people
socially distanced clapping very slowly
and she's like shouting at them quad way
um well yes these people should be in
charge of all the things in your life
all of them the the doddering
adult old man who can't get through a
full paragraph without his handler
stepping in and stopping the questioning
and dr joe biden the greatest the
greatest doctor in america
and the rest of this crew all these
politicians they should definitely run
your life
they know all the things there are to
know and the media are so excited about
this they're so excited because
yesterday joe biden brought forth the
greatest economic recovery plan we have
ever not needed ever
when i say we don't need it i mean
because we don't need it i mean because
the pandemic is basically over guys
okay like i understand that the media
want to panic you about there's gonna be
a fourth wave in the united states
no no there's not there's going to be an
uptick in certain states that didn't get
the vaccinations out fast enough and
where
there are not enough people who had
natural immunity from the virus
okay this is why you have not seen a
massive uptick in states like texas and
florida
and you have seen an uptick in places
like new york new jersey maryland
in other words the places that lock down
the hardest are still getting
natural herd immunity through people
transmitting the virus
but places like florida that did not
lock down those places
had a certain level a certain baseline
level of transmission that created a
natural
growth in the virus in the numbers so
that herd immunity was closer than it
was
for some of these other places okay but
the economy is in recovery the airlines
are basically operating at full capacity
people are going back to work most of
our elderly population in the major
states is now vaccinated
we're like this close to normal we're
really really close to normal and the
data are in
if you're vaccinated the reality is
you're not
at risk of transmitting the disease that
is according to the cdc you are not
at risk of dying of the disease if you
have the vaccinations so you're good to
go you really don't need to be wearing a
mask
we are this close to normal and so on
top of that joe biden has decided we're
going to prolong
the fake crisis just long enough yes
long enough to
squeeze through a bunch of massive bills
massive bills that radically change the
way that labor works
in the united states and the new york
times could not be more pumped about it
because again their theory is that joe
biden knows what's best for you
joe biden doesn't know what's best for
himself joe biden
doesn't know whether to to go for the
can of metamucil or the can of insurer
but joe biden
knows what is best for you and so do all
these politicians they know what's best
for you
what is the theory here according to the
new york times the theory is that public
spending
is the key to competitiveness because as
we all know from history
you know what makes a country super
competitive taking enormous amounts of
money
and then redistributing it via
government to people
the soviet union tried this for like 80
years worked out fantastically
fantastically china is trying it right
now
all they've had to do is build ghost
cities and rack up massive amounts of
debt like everybody thinks of china
as the wave of the economic future china
is not the wave of the economic future
china
is a very economically fragile country
that has been able to survive basically
off of predation of its own population
okay the way that you actually create
economic success is by allowing people
to make
self-interested economic decisions this
has been true for several hundred years
actually has been true for all of human
history but it was discovered at the
beginning of the enlightenment
in about 1800 and you can see the
exponential increase in living standards
and gdp
global gdp over that time but biden's
strategy is basically let's go back to
mercantilism makes perfect sense let's
go back to the government running
everything
according to the new york times patricia
cohen
is the reporter president biden's
ambitious plan to increase corporate
taxes
does more than just reverse much of the
overhaul pushed through by his
predecessor it also offers a profoundly
different vision
of how to make the united states more
competitive and how to flip the bill
when president trump and a republican
congress rewrote the tax code in 2017
most of the benefits went to the
wealthiest americans with lower rates on
businesses and on profits from
investments
well here's the thing whenever people
say this kind of crap where they're like
most of the benefits of a tax cut one to
the people who are the wealthiest
there's another way to phrase that
most of the benefits of a tax cut go to
people who pay the most taxes
of course of course because the fact of
the matter is
that the top one percent of people in
this country pay an
overwhelming and overwhelming burden of
taxes the top
fifty percent pay all of the taxes the
top ten percent pay something like
eighty percent of the taxes so if you
have a tax cut
whose taxes you gonna cut people who
aren't paying taxes
but the animating idea according to the
new york times behind biden's tax plan
is that the best way to increase
america's competitiveness and foster
economic growth is to raise corporate
taxes to finance huge investments in
transportation broadband utilities and
more so if you liked
the solyndra scam of the obama years the
giant stimulus package get ready gang
we're about to get that except times
three
plus a bunch of labor restrictions as
well
the business roundtable us chamber of
commerce and national association of
manufacturers all welcomed the idea of
pumping money into repairing and
building the nation's infrastructure but
recoiled at raising corporate taxes to
do so so first of all the idea that
america's infrastructure is in a state
of complete collapse is just not true
about the 13th best infrastructure
according to international sources
of any country on earth state
infrastructure varies widely by state
most of the infrastructure that is
failing is not federal infrastructure it
is state infrastructure which means
it should be paid for by state tax
dollars if infrastructure in california
is failing there's no reason that
taxpayers in florida should be paying
for that state infrastructure
also it happens to be the case that when
you measure gdp stats one of the big
problems with gdp
is gdp only measures dollars spent so if
a government spends a dollar that is the
same as if you or i spend a dollar the
difference is that if you or i spend a
dollar building a business
that creates add-on effects in terms of
creating new jobs
creating new products creating new
services that is why gdp is not actually
a wonderful measure of how well people
are doing
if you are getting more for the same
money then why exactly is the gdp the
same
gdp has always been a very flawed
measure of economic growth but
it is particularly flawed when it comes
to government spending which can
artificially boost
the gdp so he's pushing brand new taxes
he's pushing
massive new spending is joe biden and
the new york times is super excited
about it
super excited we'll get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about your sleep quality
well you know sometimes i don't have a
great night's sleep and um
that's usually when i'm away from home
and trying to soldier through the next
day after i've had a bad night's sleep
it always feels gross and yucky and
you're just trying to get through the
day
you need a good night's sleep most
people don't think that much about how
they spend one third of their day
namely sleeping being in bed okay well
that means you have to have a great
mattress a mattress made
just for you this is where helix sleep
comes in helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to the
mattress comes directly to your doorship
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
and by gq and wired magazine head on
over to helixsleep.com
ben take that two minutes leave quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you
the best sleep of your life 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but yeah
absolutely well my wife and i have a
helix sleep mattress it has improved our
sleep quality immensely
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
best deal of the year thus far 200 bucks
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners helixsleep.com
ben okay so biden's plans are of course
massive uh they blow out the budget to
the tune of another two trillion dollars
even the washington post is going this
is a lot of money according to heather
long when the white house released what
it hailed as its historic infrastructure
plan on wednesday
it said corporate tax changes would
quote more than pay for the mostly
one-time investments in the american
jobs plan
but there is a catch the 2.3 trillion
dollars in spending would take place
over the next eight years it would take
until 2036
15 years for biden's proposed corporate
tax hikes to generate that much revenue
so in other words the vast majority of
this is deficit spending
the disconnect is one of several
controversies the biden's proposal is
already facing
especially as the president tries to
garner bipartisan votes not trying
bipartisan votes by the way they've
already said they're not trying
bipartisan votes democratic
representative buyer says we're going to
use reconciliation that means we're
ramming this sucker through with 50
votes plus kamala harris remember that
time
when i said that republicans who didn't
show up in georgia to vote for those
senate seats we're doing the country an
enormous disservice yeah you know i've
been super helpful right now republicans
running the senate here's democratic
representative byers
just spilling out that this is not going
to be a bipartisan bill in any way
i think all of us including the
president and secretary of body judge
would prefer to have it be bipartisan
you know at least 10 republican senators
and there will be many many good things
in there for
the constituents of our republican
office holders but we're not going to
not do it because they won't come along
but they'll be invited to be part of it
influence it help guide it but at the
end of the day
if they're going to say no then we will
proceed with reconciliation
i love that they're going to be invited
to vote for it and then if they say no
then we're just going to do what we want
oh that sounds super bipartisan there
guys remember that time joe biden was a
bipartisan moderate
yeah that's not real by the way how much
of this two trillion dollar bill goes
towards roads and bridges when you hear
infrastructure that's what you thought
right
you thought roads and bridges how much
of it goes toward roads and bridges
five percent five percent of the two
trillion dollars goes toward roads and
bridges
the other 95 goes toward various
basically buy-offs for a bunch of
democratic constituencies particularly
unions
that's what's really in the bill is a
radical rethinking of the relationship
between
labor and employment in the united
states and the federal government
so joe biden says don't worry we're just
going to ram this thing through
that the divisions at the moment
shouldn't stop us the right thing is for
us to just do it
on him then he fell asleep and his
handler shoot everybody away here was
joe biden
i don't think you'll find a republican
today in the house or senate maybe i'm
wrong
gentlemen who doesn't think we have to
improve our infrastructure
they know china and other countries are
eating our lunch
so there's no reason why i can't be
bipartisan again
the divisions of the moment shouldn't
stop us from doing the right thing for
the future
yeah you know it shouldn't yeah
bipartisan divisions shouldn't stop us
from just ramming everything through
captain bipartisanship in moderation
there that was his entire campaign yeah
it doesn't exist also
joe biden made clear what this really is
a lot of this bill should stay
boondoggle for the unions so union
representation in the united states is
down to about eight percent of the
workforce that's particularly true in
the private sector in the public sector
it's about 30 40 of the public sector
workforce is unionized which is insane
it should be illegal for public sectors
to be unionized you're bargaining
against the taxpayer
in a normal union situation the way that
the unionization typically works is that
you have a union and the union
represents the employees first of all i
will say the national labor relations
act is a piece of crap it's a terrible
piece of legislation we abide by every
jot and tittle of the national labor
relations act i have to say that
otherwise the national labor relations
board sends me a nasty note about how
they're going to infringe on my first
amendment rights but the national labor
relations act
piece of crap legislation we abide by
every single aspect of it because we
have to by federal law
but it basically means that if you get
50 of employees in a particular industry
to sign on to a union then the employer
is forced by federal law
to negotiate with that 50 percent yeah
which is crazy because you still have 49
of people who didn't actually want to
join the union and now you have the 51
collectively bargaining on behalf of
people who never wanted to join the
union in the first place
and what what happened is that in the
private sector there were right-to-work
laws that were passed
in about 27 states these right-to-work
laws said that you
as a non-member of the union did not
have to pay union dues to the union and
so people stopped paying union dues and
at that point people stopped joining the
union
and when people stopped joining the
union you didn't have money unions
started to disband
and so what biden is attempting to do is
revivify unions by killing right to work
laws he wants to make it
so that you must pay union dues even if
you are not a member of a union
in so-called right-to-work states he
also wants to make sure that we unionize
a vast swath of american industry
he's imitating california's assembly
bill 5. assembly bill 5 in california
was a provision
of law that did not pass in california
that was an attempt
to basically turn every independent
contractor in california
into an employee it was about to kill
uber it was about to kill lyft i believe
it didn't pass
and assembly bill 5 will now be
federalized the goal would be to take
every independent contractor and force
them into a union
that is the goal here and biden is not
making any bones about this right he's
admitting straight off exactly what his
agenda here is
so let's listen to joe biden with his
real agenda so joe biden's actual real
agenda here
is to push the unions because the unions
have the most openly corrupt bargain in
american politics the unions
take money from people who are not
members of unions in non-right-to-work
states they then use that money to elect
democrats
then they use those democrats to either
pass more favorable union laws or in the
public sector they bargain directly with
the democrats
for more lucrative contracts it is so
openly corrupt
it's astonishingly corrupt for people
who are always talking about campaign
finance reform money and politics it's
so bad they never point out that unions
spend billions of dollars every election
cycle in order to elect people with whom
they then bargain
perfectly openly it's unbelievable it's
super super
it is super corrupt it is venal beyond
belief anyway joe biden is totally in
the pocket of the unions here he was
admitting it yesterday
and it's true mike you're a union guy me
too
i got in trouble but i don't make any
apologies for it
i'm a union guy i support unions unions
built the middle class
it's about time they start to get piece
of the action
uh main mistake there by the way ab5 is
in effect in california and it's been
devastating
for an enormous number of small
businesses the fact that
joe biden is out there saying that
unions built the middle class
no you know what built the middle class
of this country employers
employers built the middle class unions
without employers didn't build the
middle class
and guess what america had a thriving
middle class going all the way back to
alexis to tocqueville
what made america unique is that america
had so much class mobility from the very
beginning
the notion that without unions the
middle class wouldn't exist is just a
lie it is not true
okay unions have been on the wane in the
united states since the 1970s
and the vast majority of people who were
in the middle class became upper middle
class when you hear this myth that the
middle class disappeared in the united
states
no what happened is that most of the
people who were in the middle class
joined the upper middle class by
statistics
okay but none of the real economic
reality doesn't matter
because it's not about economic reality
it's about pushing an agenda
it's about it we don't need any of this
we had a historically good economy
before covet then we had an artificial
downturn because of covet and now we are
coming out of the artificial downturn
and on top of that
joe biden wants to quote unquote build
back better which means presumably that
he wants to completely restructure the
american economy that had generated
unprecedented wage growth for the last
50 years
and he wanted an economy that had
produced 3.5
unemployment naturally so he's proposing
these massive tax increases
he's proposing this massive spending
he's going to raise the debt
by a trillion dollars in the first six
months of 2021 alone
and according to the wall street journal
editorial board joe biden is already
pushing corporate tax increases
his corporate tax increase alone is more
than 1.5 trillion over 10 years
another 1.5 trillion coming soon on
individual income and investment has
about 300 billion bucks a year or 1.36
percent of gdp every year
assuming a u.s gdp of 22 trillion this
is the largest tax increase
since 1968 and you remember the booming
economy of the 1970s
so you can get ready for that it'll be
fantastic biden's corporate tax increase
amounts to the restoration of the
obama-era corporate tax burden only much
more so
the gop tax reform of 2017 was designed
to fix a corporate tax system that was
uncompetitive and convoluted
companies paid taxes in countries where
they earned the income then again if
they returned the money to the u.s
trillions of dollars piled up overseas
remember the string of corporate
inversions when ceos move their
headquarters those inversions all but
ended
after 2017 because reform lowered the
top corporate tax rate to 21
from 35 percent and moved the us closer
to a territorial tax system
where you pay tax where the income is
earned however biden wants to raise the
corporate tax rate up to 28 but he also
wants to add penalties that would make
inversions punitive so if you take your
company
offshore then he would try to penalize
you he would impose a global minimum
corporate tax of 21
so if you earn all of your money
overseas you get penalized for basing
yourself in the united states
this would shoot the tax burden on u.s
companies back toward the top of the
developed world list
at least nine major countries have cut
their corporate tax rate since 2017
including all of the left's favorite
supposedly socialistic countries like
sweden and the netherlands
the larger biden goal is to end global
tax competition much as its ban on state
tax cutting seeks to end
income tax competition among the 50
states
the united states can lead the world to
end the race to the bottom on corporate
tax rates
yeah except that people aren't going to
do that the reality is that if you want
to have a rich country right now you
lower your taxes then you draw the
businesses there
hilariously the biden administration is
making the claim number one that this
will have no impact on people at the
bottom levels of the economy
and number two that if you raise the
corporate income tax
somehow this is going to not let people
flee okay so here is joe biden saying
nobody
making under 400 000 will see a tax
increase that's just a lie once you
raise the corporate income tax there are
a lot of people who are the heads of
corporations
who feel that in the pocketbook not
everybody who owns an llc
earns personally more than 400 000 a
year so if you increase corporate tax
rates
who do you think corporations represent
corporations
are indeed rep they're legal structures
that represent humans
so this is just not true here is joe
biden saying and untruth but we should
be used to that by now
no one making under four hundred
thousand dollars
will see their federal taxes go up
period
this is not about penalizing anyone
i have nothing against millionaires and
billionaires i believe american american
capitalism
i want everyone to do well but here's
the deal
right now middle class couple a
firefighter and a teacher
with two kids making a combined salary
of say 110 120 000
a year pays 22 cents for each
additional dollar they earn a federal
income tax
but a multinational corporation that
builds a factory abroad
brings it homes and sells they pay
nothing at all
okay what is he talking about these
multinational corporations pay
extraordinary tax over and over again
people are always saying
amazon doesn't pay tax they pay sales
tax in virtually every state in the
union
the the notion that that people and the
employees of amazon pay income tax
notice also how he shifts the topic
there because the reality is that the
couple making 120 000
a year on a percentage basis of income
they're not paying in nearly but a
person who makes a million dollars a
year is paying based on percentage
income
i know because i've made a wide variety
of salaries and wages over the course of
my years
in the workforce i know exactly what
i've paid every single year
and let me tell you it escalates real
fast the basic idea that people at the
top end of the income spectrum aren't
paying their quote unquote fair share is
just an overt lie
in terms of net tax inter like getting
things back from the government
the top 10 percent are paying all of it
all net tax in the united states
according to the american enterprise
institute
okay so the the biden plan here is to
blow out the spending
it's to rethink the government's
relationship with labor it's to
make everybody basically a union member
so that they can be a de facto
bargainer with the government and it's
to spend a bunch of crap
just a crapload of money on sillinesses
brad palumbo has a pretty good list over
at the
freedom and economic enterprise
institute foundation for economic
education rather
there's 10 billion dollars to create a
civilian climate corp
a civilian climate corps the white house
claims the 10 billion
investment will put a new diverse
generation to work conserving our public
lands and waters does that sound like
infrastructure to you
20 billion to advance racial equity and
environmental justice
20 billion dollars that's more than the
latest coverage package spent on
vaccines by the way
for a program that will reconnect
neighborhoods cut off by historic
investments and ensure new projects to
increase opportunity
advance racial equity and environmental
justice 175 billion dollars in subsidies
for electric vehicles
except for the fact that you know people
are already buying electric vehicles if
they're good and not if they suck
213 billion dollars to build and
retrofit two million houses
and buildings 100 billion new dollars
for new public schools and making school
lunches greener
they're going to get rid of paper plates
and other disposable materials in
schools
billions to eliminate racial and gender
inequities in
science technology engineering and math
all this sounds like infrastructure
spending too doesn't it
five percent again five percent of this
bill actually goes to roads and bridges
that's what's actually in here complete
remaking of america
along the lines of just basic lies the
new york times loves it by the way their
headline today
is this it's just this sycophantic
biden to save jobs restructuring economy
again this is the greatest economy in
the history of the world or
was before covet hit it and the basic
notion is that we have to somehow
restructure this dramatically
really well well done everybody
meanwhile they have big immigration
plans too
their immigration plans involve
basically doing nothing on the border
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact you don't
want to go to an auto parts store right
now in fact you don't ever want to go to
an auto parts store
the weather is warming up the last thing
you want to be doing is waiting at an
auto parts
store for hours you wait there wait to
get to the front of the line
and then finally they they don't have
the part they have to order it in they
up
charge you why not just you know go
straight to the people who can bring you
the part directly that's rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same part like let's say hypothetically
you happen to need just off the top of
my head because this is my thing a
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a big
chain store that's the kind of thing you
could get at rock auto for 217 bucks
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts you shouldn't instead
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you that is rockauto.com
all right we'll get to more in just one
second because we haven't even gotten to
the height of the stupidity of this
administration yet
but first as you've probably heard
candice joined the daily wearer a few
weeks ago at the premiere of her new
talk show canvas
that shows streams at dailywire.com
fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
but
you can get the audio podcast canvas on
apple spotify wherever you listen to
your podcast candice hosts a series of
guests on the show every week making for
lively panel discussions insightful
interviews honestly my favorite part of
candace's
show is her cancel corner or she sort of
does direct to camera messaging to
people it's pretty fantastic
featured guests have included people
like jacqueline willing and brandon
tatum and john rich to name a few
candice is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live audience don't
worry
if you can't attend the show in person
tweet your questions to the candice show
at the candice show for a chance to have
candice answer your question at the end
of her show
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a 5
star review
if you like what you hear go check out
candace's show right now
and by the way you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
well meanwhile as the biden
administration pushes this
world-breaking change on an economy that
really doesn't need it
because obviously these are the smartest
people and they should be in charge the
smartest people who are in charge of the
border have decided basically to just
leave the border open and they're not
going to do anything
about it the deputy border patrol chief
admitted yesterday there would be
over a million apprehensions or
experiences at the border this year
face-offs between border patrol and
people attempting to cross the border
illegally here was that
pool factors are attracting more
migrants to the south texas border
where deputy chief raul ortiz predicts
overall
a record-breaking year based upon what
we've already apprehended
in looking at what's remaining in in the
fiscal year that we will have
approximately about a million
apprehensions or encounters this year
so sound good right well the good news
is the divided administration again
they only put the best people in charge
right here's the thing
between son ambulance joe and dr jill
the grace of all doctors
and the and the rest of this genius
administration
they've decided they're putting vice
president harris in charge of the border
i mean because what we definitely need
is somebody whose first reaction to
every awkward question is to cackle like
the joker
she's been put in charge of the border
they said this a week ago she's not gone
down to the border so far as i'm aware
nor has she actually given a press
conference on the border so far
somewhere but
she did speak to the hispanic chamber of
commerce and say that help is here
shisa puad way or something here is a vp
harris
this past year it's been difficult
both for your bottom line and for your
peace of mind
one in four small businesses have closed
thousands
owned by latinos these numbers reinforce
what we already know the situation is
urgent
when the president and i were preparing
to take office
he promised that help is on its way well
now help is here
um help is here is it
well i'm noticing on the border there
are some people who seem
disproportionately hispanic and origin
and the help isn't there
as it turns out it turns out that in
some of these facilities you're holding
people
at like a thousand percent of capacity
so
you haven't been down there every time
you get asked a question you just start
cackling
like a crazy person but help is
here or something well the good news is
we will always have
stalwart fighters for the people at the
border their human rights
store fighters like alexander
ocasio-cortez now
let's be real about this she is just a
breath of fresh air
she is she is so fresh so face
i mean not just a fresh face so fresh
and so faced alexandra
ocasio-cortez in fact she is so fresh
and so faced that she brought her super
fresh superface
all the way down to the border you'll
remember during the trump administration
where in a totally spontaneous
non-planned
public relations act she ended up at a
fence
in front of a parking lot that was a
ways away from a border facility
and there she broke down in a pure
display
of unbridled compassion and emotion in
which you stare directly into camera
for some reason while wearing a
perfectly
white outfit because feminist power
and you remember is these these amazing
pictures of just the incredible emotion
on display when she saw the cruelty
the malevolence the malice the brutality
of the trump administration and their
treatment of illegal immigrants
at the border holding kids in cages and
she couldn't take it anymore
and she went down there and like sarah
connor in terminator 2 in the dream
sequence she put her hands in the
chain-link fence
and she screamed to the heavens why oh
god
why would you allow such evil to take
place
on this planet and in this country why
well now
joe biden is holding like a multiple of
that number of kids
in cages and they're like packed
together in the middle of a coveted
pandemic
and aoc has not been down to the border
probably she just hasn't had time or
something
she's super sincere and brilliant she
she probably just hasn't had time to be
down
at the border or maybe that white outfit
is still at the dry cleaners i mean it's
been like a couple of years but it's not
a great dry cleaners to be honest with
you
and and maybe that photographer was i
don't know like
booked okay but she hasn't been down to
the border or anything but
she did have time to do an insta
she did an insta and when she did her
insta she discussed what is happening on
the border and let me just say
the pearls of wisdom floweth like water
from that so fresh so face here is aoc
talking about
the border crisis and saying some of the
most
intellectually incisive things i have
ever heard
about the border it's like when einstein
i'm sure would give a disquisition
on the physics of relativity that's like
aoc on border policy
except einstein was up was a
just i mean like she is just the amount
of intellectual firepower here
it's it's pretty astonishing i i will
say that here she was
really sounding off you know in
emotional fashion about what's happening
under president biden at the border
where again a multiple of children are
now being held and we're ever held
under under trump often people want to
say
why are you talking about the border
crisis or why aren't you talking about
it in this way
well we're talking about it they just
don't like how we're talking about it
because it's not a border crisis it's an
imperialism crisis it's a climate crisis
it's a trade crisis
anyone who's using the term surge around
you
consciously is trying to invoke a
militaristic frame
and that's a problem because
these this is not a surge these are
children and they are not insurgents
and we are not being invaded
[Music]
deep thoughts mind-blown i mean it is
it's not a border crisis guys it's an
imperialism
crisis don't you see it's because
america invaded
these central and latin american nations
and all these people they didn't cross
the border the bore across them
or alternatively they crossed the border
illegally but it's an imperialism crisis
also
it's a climate crisis sure it's not a
climate crisis
sure you're blaming all the on a
hurricane that happened like months and
months and months ago and then the
search started
and the surge happened like way after
the hurricane but it's a climate crisis
guys it is not a policy crisis there is
no crisis on the border it's a figment
of your imagination
you know how i know because if it were a
crisis on the border she'd be down there
in a white outfit crying at the border
that's how you know
i don't have to watch the news i don't
have to i don't have to pay attention to
any of the stats
all i have to do is watch whether aoc is
taking an emotionally overwatch photo at
the border to tell whether we have a
climate crisis or a border crisis
and she says no border crisis i believe
her no border crisis guys
it is not a border crisis it is an
imperialism crisis it's a climate crisis
and it is a
trade crisis because the balance of
trade
is off or there aren't tariffs or
something
i know that when we have a trade dispute
with canada we immediately get a huge
surge
of canadians just coming over that
northern border happens all the time
we've been having
this massive trade standoff with the
chinese government and that's what we've
been getting is just an enormous number
of chinese expatriates just
leaving just right there on the border
amazing
because that's how trade policy works
guys it's incredible
also surge don't use the word surge
never use the word serge
you can't do it don't use the word surge
because if you use the word surge you
are invoking
insurge ins you see you should put a
prefix
and a suffix you put in and ins
before and after the lord surge and boom
you're using a militaristic frame
when you say there's a surge normally
this is what i think like
when let's say the lights go out in my
house right and i think oh my gosh maybe
there was a power surge
i'm using a militaristic frame because
what i really mean is that my
electricity
is a gorilla force it is an insurgent
force
when i put a surge protector into the
wall to stop that sort of thing from
happening
that's because i'm an imperialist and
i'm attempting to stop those guerrilla
insurgents electrics
from invading my toaster surge insurgent
same thing same thing see here's the
thing she knows the deep etymology of
these words she understands that both
words
actually do come from the latin word for
rise this is true that's what she knows
she knows that
and she knows that when you say there's
a surge of people at the border what you
mean
you bastard what you mean
is that children are like terrorist
militants
also she knows that not only does serge
mean that
follow the logic here okay when you say
surge
what you really mean is that one one
time you knew an eastern european guy
named
serge and serge was not the best guy
serge was the kind of guy who wouldn't
pick you up at the airport and that made
you think
of insurgents so when you said surge
you meant that guy surge who's a bad guy
and also
made you think of insurgents and so you
are just slamming all that together to
rip on the children and that's the
problem here
these people you want these people in
charge
that's what you want these ones
these ones seriously
okay but if that's not good enough for
you i'm gonna bring you some more
brilliance from the democratic party
because
it is just and by the way again there
are morons in the republican party too
many morons everywhere but the ones in
the republican party say they don't want
to run your life
that is the difference if i'm given the
choice between a who wants to
control my life and a who doesn't
want to control my life i will always
pick the who doesn't want to
control my life
but we have more morons for you today
today is morante on the april fool's
episode of the ben shapiro show john
is here the climate envoy because when i
think of a man who takes climate very
seriously i think of a guy
who goes around a personal jet wind
surfs for fun really in touch with the
commoners is john kerry
you know not all of us had the ability
to marry a ketchup heiress and then use
her money to run for office
not all of us had that ability some of
us actually had to build businesses and
stuff but john kerry knows how it's done
john kerry is he this is an amazing
advocate especially for people in the
developing world who are burning dung
for fuel
john kerry's an amazing advocate he
wants them to have solar panels
sure the solar panels won't connect to
anything and they'll still have to burn
dung for fuel and they'll die at early
ages because they don't have
carbon-based technologies but
john kerry is there for them and you
know he's sympathetic to them because he
flies around in a private jet and says
so
so john kerry is pushing climate change
again he's doing this as part of the
infrastructure plan because again you
thought the infrastructure bill was all
about roads and bridges
it was about whatever is the stupid
priority of the democratic party today
so here is john kerry saying
mother earth is screaming at us
sort of like my wife does sometimes
john kerry speak to us oh oh wise one
we're here because of science this is
not politics this is not ideology oh
this is not some political goal this is
not a pet project
of one or two or three countries this is
a reality that the scientists for years
have been telling us and mother earth
the planet is screaming at us with the
feedback loops that are telling us
every single day get this done
that mother earth is screaming at us
screaming now my favorite part of this
is where john kerry fully admits that
the paris climate accord that he helped
negotiate is a complete piece of crap
and he's like also by the way if we had
kept to our commitments in the paris
climate accord
requirements still would have gone warm
yes you know who used to say that a lot
because it's true
your policies suck dude i can totally
understand
the climate is getting warmer but all of
your policies are not geared toward
making the climate less warm they are
geared toward redistributionism
internationally and you openly
acknowledge it here's john kerry saying
that paris climate accord we used to
brag about it doesn't do anything but we
were gonna make you do it anyway weren't
we
you suckers oh face all collapsing like
a mudslide in the hollywood hills here's
john kerry
paris was a giant leap forward nope but
even if we did
everything that we promised to do in
paris
earth's temperature will still rise to
about 3.7 degrees if we did everything
in paris
and we're not so if
if if we are looking at the curve we're
on now
we're actually headed over four degrees
i don't want to debate how much
it's a debate nobody can win but when
the scientists
uniformly tell us we're heading on this
terrible curve
we know we have to speed up we know we
have to speed up guys
you know that's what we should do we
should absolutely wreck the economy
because
he's not going to debate the science the
science is clear except for how it's not
clear and the ipcc has an estimate
anywhere from
like two to five degrees celsius
increase by the end
of the century which is a pretty wide
range and also we don't know the
sensitivity of the climate and if we
didn't know the sensitivity of the
climate is pretty obvious that if
america went to zero carbon emissions
today
net zero it still would not prevent the
amount of global warming that is baked
into the cake and so we should really be
focusing our income
not so much on mitigation as on
adaptation but we can't talk about any
of that
by the way there's nothing in this bill
when it comes to green energy and all
this kind of stuff
how about building sea walls right how
about geo engineering not much in there
for that
nope just a bunch in there for
stimulating a bunch of joe biden's
political allies
and john kerry sees it as an economic
opportunity which is the important thing
it's an economical a man who's never
built a job in his entire life and lived
off the back of either
the public fortune or his wife's fortune
here he is saying it's an economic
opportunity
this is the greatest economic
opportunity we've ever had to build our
countries
every job we need to do to do this build
out a grid
build solar power wind power
do hydrogen every every list
building batteries switching to
electronic vehicles electric vehicles
all require jobs every one of those are
people working
oh it's great you know because every
time you wreck the economy that requires
jobs if we just have you like make mud
pies on the side of the road
because it turns out that your job was
really carbon emitting but you know it's
a job that isn't carbon emitting you're
digging a hole and filling it back in
that's an economic opportunity the
geniuses let them
for sure they will make things better
these geniuses it'll just be
spectacular alrighty we will be back
here later today with an additional hour
of the ben shapiro show this week
michael moles is guest hosting
so make sure to turn in also coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director
is pavel wydowski editing is by adam's
psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the mat wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show
you